wird das mammut schon bald wiederbelebt
forschungsteams tüfteln schon länger
daran science fiction drehbücher zur
realität werden zu lassen und sie sind
tatsächlich optimistisch dass sie
bereits in naher zukunft ausgestorbene
tiere wie etwa das mammut wieder zum
leben erwecken können und das könnte
wiederum eines unserer größten probleme
der zeit lösen den klimawandel
verlangsamt wie man genau das mammut von
den toten wieder erwecken will und alle
weiteren infos zu diesem atemberaubenden
plant jetzt in fix und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
es geht um marmor wandert tauben und den
magen brüter frosch das sind einige der
tierarten die längst ausgestorben sind
die aber demnächst vielleicht wieder auf
der erde leben könnten zumindest wenn es
nach dem plan der so genannten die
extinction bewegung geht grob übersetzt
sind dass die leute die sich um die
wiederbelebung ausgestorbener tierarten
kümmern der genetiker george church ist
daran beteiligt und forscht an der
renommierten harvard university in
boston manche bezeichnen ihn als den
einstein unserer zeit seinen plan er
will ein embryo entwickeln das halb
elefant und halb wollhaarmammut ist und
dass in naher zukunft das hat er im
februar diesen jahres auf einer
wichtigen wissenschaftskonferenz der
american association for the advancement
of science aaas oder es in boston
verkündet beide tiere kennen wir
elefanten aus dem zoo oder einer safari
und das wollhaarmammut aus dem museum
groß wie der heutige steppen elefant aus
afrika aber deutlich kräftiger stoßzähne
die nach oben zeigen und ein langes
zotteliges fell seit 4000 jahren etwa
ausgestorben doch bald werden sie wieder
durch die tundra trampeln und dabei
vielleicht sogar den klimawandel stoppen
bot also von vorne
forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten schon
seit jahrzehnten daran längst
ausgestorbene tiere von den toten zu
erwecken
doktor frankenstein quasi mit
verschwundenen tieren vor rund 14 jahren
hatten sie zellkerne aus dem letzten
exemplar der ausgestorbenen pyrenäen
steinböcke entnommen und diese in ziegen
eingesetzt und das ganze war wirklich
vielversprechend im sommer 2003 kam ein
steinböck land zur welt und lebte
allerdings nur für kurze zeit nach
wenigen minuten erstickt ist zurück zum
mammutprojekt forschungsteams hatten es
tatsächlich relativ einfach das erbgut
von mammut zu entschlüsseln
denn im permafrost der tundra gab es
ziemlich gut erhaltene mammut überreste
zu finden
das genom des prähistorischen mannes
wurde also sequenziert doch das problem
hierbei das erbgut zu entschlüsseln
heißt eben noch lange nicht zu wissen an
welcher position welcher gegend
bausteinen liegt doch die sogenannte
christa methode ein genetisches werkzeug
war dass wir hier ja schon öfter
berichtet haben die hilft da enorm
weiter mit dieser technik lassen sich
gibt
ausschneiden verändern und auch wieder
in fremdes erbgut einsetzen der
molekularbiologe church hat nach eigenen
angaben seit 2015 mehr als 45 mammut
gehen stücke in das erbgut des
asiatischen elefanten eingesetzt das ist
der nächste noch lebende verwandte des
wollhaarmammuts ganz wichtig dieser
prozess ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit dem
klonen wie es etwa im film jurassic park
der fall ist es irgendwann tatsächlich
also eine art mama fand zum leben
erweckt werden würde hätte es auch schon
eine heimat im nordosten sibiriens hat
ein team aus ökologen und ökologie die
tundra zurück in die eiszeit gebiet auf
einer gasstätte neben bereits große
pflanzenfresser wie wisente und rentiere
das sogenannte willi members projekt
verspricht sich von diesem plan großes
denn die dann ausgewilderten mammuts
könnten tatsächlich helfen den
klimawandel zu bekämpfen
manche von euch wissen vielleicht das im
permafrost der sibirischen steppe
gigantische mengen an kohlenstoff
eingeschlossen sind und durch die
erwärmung der erde kommen wir immer
näher an den punkt an dem der permafrost
taut und genau das will das projekt
verhindern denn dann würde der
kohlenstoff entweichen denn tiere wie
bisons rentiere oder eben auch mammuts
fressen riesige mengen an pflanzen und
das fördert das wachstum des steppengras
und dadurch würde tatsächlich weniger
permafrost owen die erklärung dazu die
hellen gräser reflektieren das
sonnenlicht ähnlich wie ein spiegel die
erde nimmt weniger wärme auf ein
genialer plan und natürlich eine riesige
revolution in der wissenschaft doch dazu
muss ja erst einmal das wollhaarmammut
von den toten auferstehen und davon ist
das projekt tatsächlich noch entfernt
hinzu kommen mehr als ein bis zwei
moralische und ethische bedenken
kritiker sagen die beteiligten
forschungsteams würden sich durch diese
pläne wie gott aufspielen ist es auf der
anderen seite nicht eine korrektur wenn
wir menschen ausgestorbene tiere zurück
bringen deren ausrottung wir selbst zu
verantworten haben wobei das gilt nicht
für das mammut andere kritiker sprechen
von frankenstein methoden und wieder
andere fordern das investierte geld
besser zu nutzen um noch lebende arten
zu schützen als mehr als fraglich
jedenfalls bezeichnen einige andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
den plan von george church langfristig
ein war
tigges wollhaarmammut zu erschaffen
deutlich realistischer erscheint dagegen
der erste schritt dahin ein elefant mit
einigen merkmalen der eigentlichen
ausgestorbenen mammuts es wird also
wirklich sehr spannend und auch ein
bisschen spooky wie ich finde ich halte
euch hier auf jeden fall auf dem
laufenden wenn ihr mir hier ein abo aufs
auge drückt und nicht vergessen mir
einen auf die glocke zu geben denn nur
dann verpasst ihr kein video hier geht
es weiter mit und dafür drauf klicken
werden gehen soldaten jetzt realität
auch eine beängstigende perspektive bis
dann bleibt